the Joe Rogan experience do you got a
bunch of them I have my hat HPV that
goes away I got my way
HPV goes away no you still it does you
shoot a dirty load in someone you can
give it to him still well if I think I
believe that could be I could I got bad
info from my ent pretty sure you did I
had pretty sure you keep that [ __ ] we
looked this up over here I think HPV
does go away if you stop having sexual
intercourse with different people oh but
I think it goes away for you but I think
it's still in your blood and I think you
still give it to people oh we're
interesting well so don't be lying to
people when you're shooting though well
I only have sex we just put his finger
up I knew it just from the quick the
quick response in most cases HPV goes
away on its own it does not cause any
health problems but when HPV does not go
away it causes health problems like
genital warts and cancer a healthcare
provider can usually diagnose warts by
looking at the general area what if we
could've [ __ ] a health care provider
could usually diagnose warts by looking
at them yeah you can also do that
comedians can also warts a dick war
interesting yeah I had that I went to a
Planned Parenthood who do more than
abortions they'll take your warts right
off they put a little thing on there and
boom here it says they're currently no
cure for existing HPV infection but for
most people would be cleared by their
own immune system and there are
treatments available for the symptoms it
can cause you can get the HPV vaccine oh
they have a vaccine that's only for
young people that work too old causes
problems yeah yeah what does it do I
don't know what do you don't know I did
not get it Oh God it just started giving
it out recently I think in the last like
maybe less than 10 years but you gotta
be yeah you gotta get it like before
you're eight which makes you really
horny that'd be ideal right I don't know
if it cures it I guess it cures it but I
had that but so it does go away did you
ever hear about there's a story about a
drug called re-equip and it was a
medication for Parkinson's disease and
galactose SmithKline lost a judgment in
court I think it was in the tune of
$600,000 American because it turned a
guy into a gay sex and gambling addict
all he wanted to do was hook up with
guys online and gamble and in in but
listen I know it sounds crazy but they
lost the lawsuit like a pharmaceutical
drug company lost a lawsuit and the jury
awarded this guy more than a half a
million dollars how did he prove that
all he wants to do is [ __ ] guys that's a
good question but as they did they
proved it to the point where this guy
won money because he never had any
problems like this before
took his Parkinson's medication and it
just once short-circuited his brain he
started sucking dick and rolling the
dice I'm gonna sue Starbucks I've been
drinking that tea and now I want to get
came on improve I don't want to be come
done something about their tea it's not
organic there's a [ __ ] roundup in
their tea yeah something's up but I want
some loads well they're starting to pass
out lawsuits against glyphosate speaking
of that roundup that that [ __ ] that
that [ __ ] two billion dollars and
another guy got five five million well
he's a better lawyer alright cuz he got
his lawyer got him five million the
other people's lawyers got him billions
what is what's the drug oh it's not a
drug it's roundup
it's that weed killer Shillito weed
killer oh I see yeah it gives people
cancer and they're they're finally
passing down these massive judgments
against Monsanto Wow yeah the weight of
it all C Mon town so jury hits his jury
with the hits Monsanto with two billion
dollar judgment but there was that one
and then there was another one for five
plus million that guy's got to be pissed
right now the [ __ ] I only get five
million now to billion is that exact or
are they rounding up count it you should
open with that tonight at The Improv I
will I'm Hollywood hey folks you hear
about this uh this thing called roundup
most people don't know what it is you
know that's like serious GMO haters
they're they're people that are like
super organic don't want any pesticides
in their food that's it one thing that
people need to understand if you're
you're buying vegetables and you eat a
lot of vegetables
it's very good for you but man there is
a lot of [ __ ] pesticides out there
this is what's bumming me out the more I
do because I just always just ate
garbage or whatever without thinking
about it now the more research I do two
more I'll read about because I like to
read health benefits of the food I'm
eating while I'm eating it because it
makes it feel like alright I'm doing
something good but then everyone at the
bottom of the page like if you eat too
much broccoli you'll [ __ ] your blood or
whatever it's there's always something
or there's pesticides or honestly
[Applause]